qui est un navire d'exploration disponible
, l'USS Orville et nous vous proposons de
commander, vous plaisantez,
ce n'est pas mal,
oh, c'est bien de peindre des flammes sur le
côté et peut-être comme une licorne arc-en-ciel,
vous avez quelque chose engagez le lecteur quantique,
nous avons besoin de protection protection  de ce que
la trilogie tu vas mourir
il n'y a aucun moyen que nous soyons sortis à
5h00 aujourd'hui sommes-nous
je peux ouvrir ce pot de cornichons pour moi
je l'ai desserré pour vous
nous sommes au bord de la frontière de l'
exploré  espace qui ne vous excite pas
qui a mordu les premières d'Orville dimanche
10 septembre sur Fox
coucou coucou coucou